everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
we all write our own stories
[Music]
this is our story
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
what's a guy gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this
Kitty there's something in my room
sweetheart let me handle it
is
[Music]
people think they know my story
but this is how it all began
we ended together we going down and
we're going up this is my story my story
this is our story I got an idea it's a
spicy kid it's gonna change everything
you're a janitor and we know that there
was a product out there for us we'd say
take all our money
hello first
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this if
I can't undo what I did there may not be
a future
China
you are clinically dead nine months ago
fought your way back
in your predicament the black character
is always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you sacrifice the person
you deemed the blackest to blackest
Clinton yeah that can prove them that
the blackest prove it I voted for Trump
so you've never left fire town why does
anyone get to tell you what you can do
in your life I've been trying to fill my
father's shoes but I never once asked
what I wanted to do
holy Toledo that's Mitch Campbell you're
very good in the one about the in
the brothel who gets amnesian
pediatrician you're very honestly maybe
my favorite character ever I don't know
why nobody else liked it date our son
this summer and bring him out of his job
before college so when you say date him
do you mean date him or date him yes
your powers beyond your imagination
is your moment Ruby
time
I'll get to torture with Voodoo been
shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry well I've been looking for this
all my life
yeah
I'm Batman